bonsoir bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez sur public sénat
édition spéciale d' allons plus loin ce
soir nous sommes ensemble pendant une
heure et demie on va poursuivre
l'analyse des résultats du premier tour
des élections régionales un scrutin
plein de surprises plein d'enseignements
ce n'est peut-être pas fini d'ailleurs
ce soir on s'interrogera avec nos
invités sur cette résistance des partis
historiques l air et ps alors que les
alliances les fusions les retraits se
précise en paca en ile de france et
ailleurs
la région la carte des régions
pourraient ne pas beaucoup bougé à
l'issue du second tour dimanche prochain
et ce serait l'une des grandes surprises
du vote des français la revanche du
vieux monde disent certains on analysera
aussi ses revers sérieux pour le
rassemblement national et la république
en marche
quelle conclusion faudra-t-il en tirer
en vue de la prochaine présidentielle
faut-il d'ailleurs analysé ce scrutin au
niveau national autant de questions que
nous approfondirons ce soir avec nos
invités
#fb elle si vous souhaitez réagir ce
soir sur twitter mais d'abord cette
abstention historique c'est peut-être le
fait majeur de ce scrutin celui qui pose
le plus de questions
près de 90 % des 18-24 ans bouder les
urnes
toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles sont concernés ce
sont les électorats de marine le pen et
de jean luc mélenchon qui se sont le
moins déplacés
alors comment interpréter comment
analyser ce désengagement démocratique
on va en parler avec nos invités dans un
instant d'abord les chiffres c'est avec
marie brémaud deux français sur trois
décroche et inflige une sacrée gifle à
la démocratie ou en tout cas à la classe
politique
c'est la principale leçon de ce premier
tour +2 66% des français ont boudé les
urnes pour ces élections locales
un scénario d'une ampleur inédite la
sous-estimation de cette abstention
record à des conséquences massive des
conséquences massive qui interroge
l'ensemble de la classe politique
le tiers de nos compatriotes sont pas
rendus dans les bureaux de vote
c'est pour moi le premier enseignement
de ce scrutin est peut-être une source
d'inquiétude
pour le rassemblement national les
espoirs déçus s'explique par sept
abstentions
marine le pen appelle donc ses électeurs
au sursaut après avoir subi des mois de
restriction de vos libertés
je vous appelle à des confiné vos idées
et à redresser le résultat de ce premier
tour aux urnes patriots chacun tente de
trouver une explication à ce désamour
démocratique
par exemple le manque d'information sur
les compétences des départements et des
régions
on parle des collèges des lycées des
transports de la transition écologique
de l'emploi de la vie concrète des gens
je pense que nous faisons une faute
collectivement cantons sur
présidentialise le scrutin d'autres
appels à modifier les règles du scrutin
la france insoumise propose la
reconnaissance du vote blanc et d'autres
modifications
sans doute serait il temps de se
demander et nous ferons une proposition
de loi dans ce sens
s'il n'est pas nécessaire qu'il y est un
seuil minimum de participation pour
qu'une élection soient déclarés valides
dans toutes les familles politiques
on pointe du doigt une mauvaise
organisation de ce premier tour
de nombreux électeurs n'auraient pas
reçu les professions de foi des
candidats
le ministre de l'intérieur sera
d'ailleurs auditionné à ce sujet par le
sénat mercredi matin un scrutin qui pose
donc beaucoup beaucoup de questions avec
nous pour la première partie de cette
édition spéciale sabine janssen
bienvenue vous êtes professeur
d'histoire au conservatoire national des
arts et métiers rédactrice en chef de la
revue du centre d'histoire de sciences
po vous êtes vice-président du comité
d'histoire parlementaire et politique
anaïs voix gillis bienvenue vous êtes
chercheuse associée l'université de
haute-alsace et docteur en géographie
benjamin morel et également avec nous
bien venu vous êtes maître de
conférences en droit public à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas et
docteur en sciences politiques est
également avec nous jean garrigues mais
à 10 ans bienvenue jean vous êtes
historien spécialiste de l'histoire
parlementaire professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'orléans
et président du comité d'histoire
parlementaire merci donc à tous les
quatre d'être avec nous
puisque le sujet de marie s'arrête sur
ce point on va en parler tout de suite
avec vous dans jama morel le sénat va
donc auditionné ce mercredi gérald
darmanin à cause de lourdes
dysfonctionnements dans la distribution
des documents électoraux
j'imagine que c'est pas ce qui explique
l'abstention record de ce scrutin mais
ce que ça mérite effectivement de s'y
arrêter
oui ça mérite de s'y arrêter parce qu'en
réalité vous avez une nécessaire
information de l'électoral pour une
partie de l'électorat notamment pour
l'électorat âgé et bien cette
distribution là à un réel sens et peut
permettre et bien d'orienter certains
votes et pour qu'un vote soit réellement
sincère il faut que tous les électeurs
et le même degré d'information
donc là en effet il ya un sujet après si
en effet on pouvait expliquer
l'abstention par ce dysfonctionnement
je serais tenté de dire que la solution
serait simple or très clairement les
facteurs de l'abstention dans cette
affaire sont bien plus importants savez
des facteurs on y reviendra sans doute
conjoncture où vous avez des facteurs
structuraux qui implique réellement est
bien de se pencher sur ses causes et là
on est face à un incident dont les
conséquences demeurent relativement
limitées même si évidemment il faut
surtout pas que ça se reproduise surtout
dans une semaine
alors justement on va s'y arrêter sur ce
taux record d'abstention jean garrigues
est ce qu'il faut ce dire tout de suite
que oui notre démocratie est
profondément et durablement malades ou
est ce que peut-être il faut aussi
s'attendre à un sursaut au second tour
sur souhait et est toujours possible
mais de toute manière on sait bien que
le signal qui est donné par par cette
élection n'est que l'aboutissement de
toute une série d'autres signes ou qui
ont été données et on se souvient même
que aux élections lors des élections de
2017 l'abstentionnisme aurait atteint
des degrés qui était très très
inquiétant
alors aujourd'hui on a battu un record
avec deux tiers des électeurs qui ne se
soit pas déplacé mais c'est un record
qui en partie est due à des facteurs
conjoncturels la sortie du confinement
la crainte encore de 2,2 des risques
sanitaires
le beau temps et l'explosion de la
liberté retrouvée
il ya beaucoup de facteurs comme comme
celui comme celui ci il ya aussi un
facteur récurrent qui est évidemment la
compréhension des français vis-à-vis de
ce que représentent les conseils
régionaux et les conseils départementaux
la double élection enfin il ya il ya
beaucoup d'éléments chose il ya quelque
chose de très de très fort qui est
pardon mais on me demande de
m'interrompt non vous avez on a un petit
problème de liaison c'est pour ça jean
garrigues c'est pas grave on va rétablir
ce évidemment dans quelques minutes et
on va poursuivre le tour de table anaïse
willis crise sanitaire beau temps
incompréhension des fonctions des
départements et des régions tout cela
vous semble suffisant pour expliquer ce
taux record d'abstention pas je crois
pas que ce soit suffisant il faut savoir
que le beau temps on nous ressort à
chaque élection où il ya de l'abstention
et où il a fait un peu beau et où les
gens sont allés en terrasse
je crois que c'est pas suffisant pour
pour l'expliquer il ya plusieurs choses
bien en effet une incompréhension du
rôle du conseil des conseils régionaux
et des conseils départementaux et il n'y
ait vraiment une visibilité de leurs
responsabilités et surtout de leur
impact dans la vie quotidienne des gens
la deuxième chose pense qu'il ya une
méconnaissance à part les têtes de
listes les gens sur les listes sont
globalement inconnu mais hier j'ai voté
je suis dans une grande région
sur l'ensemble des gens présents il y
avait très peu de gens que je
connaissais est finalement qu on voit
assez peu dans la vie quotidienne de son
village ou de ou de sa ville donc ça
peut expliquer un peu ce désintérêt la
troisième chose qui me semble importante
c'est qu'il ya un désintérêt pour les
élections qui est liée à mon avis à une
absence ou un manque de représentation
d'une partie de nos citoyens qui ne se
retrouvent plus dans les partis
politiques traditionnels ou une fois qui
n'est pas satisfaisant et 7 non
représentation finalement on les tue dit
assez peu et quand on regarde qui se
mobilisent le moins c'est l'électorat
ouvrier et employé qui aujourd'hui bien
qu'ils aient quand il vote n'a pas de
représentation de ses intérêts au sein
de l'assemblée nationale ou du sénat
pourquoi je dis ça parce que si on
regarde le
le nombre d'ouvriers parmi nos sénateurs
ou nos députés ou même parmi les
conseillers régionaux on se rend compte
que ce n'est pas du tout représentatif
du poids des ouvriers ou des employés
dans notre société et il ya aussi le
sentiment que les partis politiques
traditionnels n'arrive plus à
transformer la vie des gens donc tous
ces facteurs mis bout-à-bout fait qu'on
arrive à une abstention aussi importante
mais je crois que dire que ce soit la
météo c'est un petit peu simplifier le
débat et puis c'est le relativiser aussi
sait relativiser la crise démocratique
profonde qui sera personnes pays depuis
plusieurs années qui ne fait que
s'amplifier d'élection c'est ce que je
peux m'arrêter une seconde sur ce que
vous avez dit les gens ne connaissaient
pas les personnes aussi pour lesquels
ils votaient ce que ça veut dire aussi
que les français ont besoin de voir les
les élus sur des plateaux télé pour se
dire ah bah je le connais je vais voter
pour lui est ce qu'il ya un peu de ça il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas que la présence
dans les plateaux et les plateaux télé
il ya aussi rendre compte de ce qu'on
fait alors les conseils conseils
régionaux de publier un petit peu
l'actualité mais il ya besoin d'avoir 70
carnation au plus près c'est pas
forcément les plateaux télé aujourd'hui
il ya elles sont énormes et l'a
rencontré dans la rue par exemple est
joué mais il n'ya pas que le président
de région je pense que vous votez aussi
pour des gens qui sont dans votre
territoire et qui sont ancrées dans
votre territoire
maintenant les plateaux télé quand on
regarde le pourcentage jeunes qui
regardent les plateaux télé je crois pas
que ce soit la réponse
il ya sûrement d'autres moyens de
sensibiliser au rôle politique et
d'incarner ce que fait la région au
quotidien et elle fait des choses
importantes
sabine janssen sans fil à des facteurs
qu'on a déjà un peu développé vous en
voyez d'autres où cela vous vend non moi
je penserai au ciel alarmiste je pense
pas que tous les français soient devenus
des pêcheurs à la ligne
je pense qu'il ya quand même une
conjoncture très très particulière
n'oublions pas qu'on était dans un état
d'urgence sanitaire depuis le mois le
mois d'octobre il ya il ya eu cent mille
morts en face et quand même pas rien
toutes les familles ont été touchées et
c'est désolant à dire mais il faut lire
au mois de juin les gens ont plus été
procurés par les étapes du déconfinement
que par les dates des élections et je
crois que les enjeux on est on a été en
en plus depuis plusieurs mois si vous
voulez dans une sorte de gestion
technique et là on est dans une phase de
transition je pense que les français ont
conservé que les enjeux n'étaient pas
suffisamment forts
je trouve quand même qu'il y avait de
l'offre politique on peut pas dire qui
avait pas d'offre politique
il y avait une offre politique
relativement large donc je pense que ça
tient beaucoup plus à l'évaluation par
les français
l'importance de ces élections voilà
davantage qu'à un vrai désintérêt quand
on regarde c'est vrai que
l'abstentionnisme est une tendance
lourde depuis la fin des années 80 mais
quand on regarde sur la longue durée
on a aussi des ddd remonter enfin c'est
pas quelque chose d talent même si c'est
vrai que globalement la tendance lourde
c'est quand même à l'augmentation de
l'abstention mais moi je ne serais pas
aussi inquiète que ça bon on n'a pas
sorti les sortants on a considéré au
fond qu'ils avaient fait est rempli leur
fait leur job comme on dit rempli leur
rôle et qu'au fond il fallait pas voulu
renverser la table on a voulu peut-être
rassurant c'est ça et il faut pas
oublier quand même qu'on a eus dernier
les dernières élections municipales on a
eu quand même si 58 % d'abstention en
pin qu'ovide je pense que c'est pas
simplement avoir la tête ailleurs c'est
un problème de hiérarchie de deux
priorités et très clairement les
français ont considéré que les enjeux
n'étaient pas fondamentaux que au fond
les présidents avaient bien travaillé et
que par ailleurs c'est ce sont nous
peut-être les commentateurs qui ont
voulu aussi nationaliser ces enjeux et
en faire sa vie certains candidats nous
ayons idéaux situation et puis on est
tous passionnés par la politique dont
premier rendez vous un peu normal on se
jette je dirais depuis mille ans le
candidat de fait ça nationalise aussi
inscrit facto on a retrouvé jean
garrigues alors je me permets de lui
laisser la parole pour qu'il termine
évidemment son raisonnement gens oui je
suis désolé mais j'entendais le nouveau
technicien pendant que je parlais samaha
tout petit peu perturbé non mais je je
je souscris à ce que dit sabine janssen
sur eux la nécessité de relativiser un
tout petit peu par rapport à cette
désaffection démocratique
mais force est de constater
effectivement que la désaffection des
jeunes rats phénomène majeur que dès que
la désaffection des couches populaires
en est un autre et mais que en même
temps est serré
pardon d utiliser cette expression qui
est très connoté mais en même temps il
ya beaucoup de paradoxes dans cette
élection parce que on fait on a fait une
campagne qu'est nationale sur la
sécurité alors que les enjeux étaient
enjeux régionaux et qu'au contraire
saison je pouvais tout à fait
intéressant à dans le débat actuel
d'autant plus qu' on est dans une
séquence quand même de re découverte des
territoires depuis 2
depuis quelques années au moins depuis
la fin des gilets jaunes on est dans une
abstention qui est a priori indique une
forme de dégagisme ça veut dire que
quand on n'est pas content de l'offre
qu'on nous donne mais ce sont les
sortants qui sont qui sont plébiscités
donc c'est tout ça est très est très
paradoxale des paradoxes yona il y en a
beaucoup regardé le le le les ceux qui
font les meilleurs scores du côté des
républicains
vous avez d'un côté xavier bertrand qui
représente on va dire une droite sociale
humaniste et puis de l'autre côté de
rang wauquiez qui est sur une ligne
beaucoup plus dur est beaucoup plus
identitaire sécurité donc il ya
énormément de paradoxe ce qui rend le le
décryptage assez compliquée avec ceux
avec cette ce phénomène d'ab science sur
macif mais le fond des choses malgré
tout c'est une réflexion qu'on doit
mener effectivement sur le divorce entre
les citoyens et les acteurs politiques
et surtout entre les citoyens et le
calendrier politique
l'acte même de voter tel qu'il est conçu
aujourd'hui je pense que beaucoup de
questions devront se poser parce que on
voit bien que à force sur présente sur
présidentialiser pardon la vie publique
la vie politique dont on se retrouve
avec une désaffection pour les élections
intermédiaires
il faut donc réfléchir à la manière dont
les concevoir aujourd'hui il me semble
le team et c'est bien sur ces questions
précisément que j'ai envie qu'on
s'arrête ce soir benjamin morel est ce
qu'on peut imaginer que les français se
soient réservées pour le scrutin
présidentiel en se disant après tout il
n'ya que celui là qui changera mon
quotidien
oui en réalité vous avez des facteurs
comme je le disais un peu tout à l'heure
conjoncture au bout et structuraux et ça
ça fait partie des codes et des facteurs
structuraux concernant les facteurs
conjoncture où vous en avez 2 qu'il faut
bien considérer d'un côté vous avez on
est aujourd'hui dans une période de
crise alors nous commentateurs
politiques ont aujourd'hui an ceux des
conflits non retrouve les joies la
politique politicienne en réalité les
français sont encore en grande partie
dans la phase sanitaires
dans toutes les périodes de crise crise
économique crise sanitaire vous voyez
deux choses vous voyez que les valeurs
de l'électorat bouge et quand vous
prenez les enquêtes d'opinion cevipof et
cetera sur les valeurs de l'électorat
vous voyez des évolutions mais vous
voyez également que l'électorat se
dépolitise c'est à dire qu'il sort des
conjonctures partisane et ça vous voyez
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui toutes
les enquêtes partout en europe où il ya
une grande stabilité des intentions de
vote sauf dans certains pays qui ont
réellement des élections nationales très
rapidement notamment l'allemagne où là
vous commencez à avoir des évolutions
sinon vous voyez en réalité que le
lecteur se dépolitiser les lecteurs à
cette élection ne sépare repolitiser on
était encore trop tôt après justement
cette crise l'autre facteur conjoncturel
et bien c'est un moment de grande
illisibilité démocratique on a beaucoup
accusaient cette campagne d'être trop
nationalisées et c'est vrai qu'elle
l'était mais les autres campagne des
régionales était également très
nationalisée regardez la france des
régions sous nicolas sarkozy
elle se colore en rose pourquoi et bien
parce que celui qui viennent les
nationales et sanctionnés aux élections
intermédiaires et que donc généralement
quand pouvoir est à droite les régions
basculent d'accord donc ça c'est un
classique c'est un classique sauf que là
c'est pas lisible c'est à dire que si
jamais je suis un électeur et que je
vais m'opposer au président de la
république parce que je nationalise
l'élection que je suis en paca je fais
quoi
pas évident parce que du coup la liste
et l'air est allié avec lé web si je
suis dans le grand est a priori
potentiellement jean rottner peut se
tourner vers m
donc il reste le vote et rennes mais si
je suis rétifs au vote et rennes c'est
compliqué donc là j'ai une illisibilité
des enjeux nationaux transcrit au niveau
local et ça pour un électeur qui ne
pense pas en termes d'élections locales
évidemment ça crée un effet d engagement
le facteur structurel benjamin le
facteur institutionnels acteurs
structuraux alors les facteurs structure
aux génériques sont de doux
qui sont double d'un côté vous avez ça a
été évoqué un facteur décentralisation
avec aujourd'hui une grande illisibilité
des compétences mais également des
statuts si je suis un électeur à lyon
pourquoi moi je vote pas pour les
départementales pas parce qu'il ya la
métropole de lyon acceptera certes mais
bon ça implique tout de même d'avoir le
nez sur le droit des collectivités
territoriales c'est complexe
si je suis alsacien je vote pour la
colle au jeu pour la commune pour la
collectivité européenne d'alsace qu'est
ce que c'est pourquoi c'est pas un
département c'en est un quelles sont les
compétences c'est extrêmement complexe
et pour les lecteurs qui n'a pas le nez
sur la réforme des collectivités
territoriales qui généralement est fait
tous les trois ans c'est aujourd'hui des
enjeux qui sont des enjeux
fondamentalement illisible et donc ça
crée un effet de désengagement parce que
du coup je vote certes mais je vote pour
quoi exactement
pour quel bilan pour quelles compétences
si jamais je vois pas d'intérêt au vote
si jamais je vois pas la portée de ce
vote j'ai pas réellement l'intérêt pour
aller me déplacer et ensuite vous
l'évoquez et c'est un point essentiel
dans la vie politique française
aujourd'hui vous avez une crise de
l'impotence du politique grosso modo si
je vote
eh bien je veux voter pour quelque chose
pour que les choses changent or notre
vie politique française est structuré
penser au tour de l'élection
présidentielle
quand est-ce que je change les choses je
le change en changeant de président de
la république c'est pas vrai vous avez
des compétences au niveau européen vous
avez des compétences au niveau des
collectivités décentralisées que pensent
les français ce qui est construit autour
de cette mystique de l'élection
présidentielle ou en réalité depuis 62
vous élisez à chaque fois un sauveur qui
peut-être ne vous aura pas sauvé six
mois plus tard mais qui se sera fait
élire sur un logiciel du sauvetage et
bien structure tout d'un coup la vie
politique française et ensuite toutes
les autres élections en dépendent
si jamais je vais voter aux élections
intermédiaires c'est pour sanctionner ou
pour porter cette élection
présidentielle sachant que le vrai
changement il aura lieu pour la plupart
des france en 2022 avait choisi c'est ce
que c'est ce qui doit nous amener à
penser à repenser les institutions les
modes de scrutin les votes les
calendriers je pense qu'il ya sûrement
un sujet de repenser les calendriers les
modes de scrutin
mais il ya aussi un grand effort de
pédagogie à faire réellement j'insiste
sur ce mot c'est à dire montrer à quoi
servent les différentes institutions et
aussi montrer que quand on prône une
simplification des institutions ce qui
était le cas notamment de cette grande
réforme des régions qui devait aboutir à
la fin des départements puis le
département sont restés et puis les
compétences des régions devait vous
les gens s'en sont en sont vraiment
perdu on prône la simplification et on
complexifie en permanence donc il ya un
avis c'est ça qu'il faut aller chercher
rien intéresser des gens entrant que
c'est un impact sur leur quotidien
parce qu'on peut on peut supprimer des
échelons ça va pas forcément donner aux
citoyens plus ce sentiment que les
choses sont selon lui qui doit faire
cette pédagogie qui doit aller les
chercher ses électeurs nous je vous nous
dites ça nous on fait ça au quotidien
d'essayer de d'expliquer ce que font les
institutions les partis politiques
oui mais le fait les chaînes de
télévision se concentrent en général
principalement plutôt sur des enjeux
nationaux plutôt sur le rôle du député
ou du sénateur plutôt sur les propos
d'ailleurs parfois en ce moment l'espace
médiatique est quand même sur occupés
plus haut par des petites polémiques des
uns et des autres des tensions qui ont
existé entre un ministre un député ou
entre deux ministres ou je ne sais qui
plutôt que par l'explication des
réformes et d'impact de ces réformes il
ya il ya bien entendu le rôle des médias
en allant vraiment dans le fond et pas
en se contentant des polémiques il ya le
rôle sûrement des collectivités ensuite
et puis après il ya aussi un travail
d'information à la fois des citoyens par
eux-mêmes et puis un travail d'éducation
populaire à faire mais je conçois que de
réponses simples
cette complexité mais il faut pas se
dire que tout tout simplifier va et que
tout sera réglé avec une réforme des
instances fusion semaine janssen non je
crois que il faut se garder de trop
toucher systématiquement les
institutions et peut-être aussi que ce
que ce que traduit l'abstention c'est
effectivement ondes et des règles qui
sont pas très lisibles une appropriation
qui n'est pas encore fait il faut pas
oublier que la réforme allait finalement
toute récente que pendant très longtemps
les français se sont inscrits dans le
cadre de ses 22 régions donc là patatras
les règles sont toutes nouvelles en plus
dans une conjoncture difficile donc je
crois que c'est monsieur temps c'est le
facteur temps qui va aussi jouer dans
cette pédagogie et qui va permettre si
je puis dire à cette pédagogie d'infuser
je crois qu'il faut du temps et je crois
qu'il faut aussi revenir il ya eu un
sondage qui a très bien montré que les
gens à 63% ont voté pour des raisons
c'est ce qu'ils disent à leurs
motivations étaient des motivations
locale c'est intéressant elles sont
peut-être pas tous à aller voter alors
que peut-être il pensait et elle et puis
alors peut-être pas le beau temps notre
choix des perfs et qu'ils n'y sont pas
allés mais je pense quand même que
clairement ils ont malgré tout et malgré
peut-être une certaine méconnaissance
des candidats c'est vrai bon le prime du
matériel électoral moi même je ne sais
pas ce qu'il en est pour vous je n'ai
pas reçu il faut dire que c'était voilà
c'était quand même c'est quand même très
problématique comme vous dites c'est une
dérive de la démographie de la même
démocratie pardon c'est quand même
l'information de tous les citoyens à
part égale donc je pense que ça c'est un
problème est précisément le fait de pas
avoir reçu le matériel électoral
ça contribue aussi un défaut
d'information parce que les gens n'ont
pas pu voir à quoi ça ressemblait au
fond un qui était là mais aussi le fait
que certes c'était régionales mais qu'
il y avait des sections départementales
c'est pas ne serait-ce que de grands
noms et dates un des scrutins les
retards
absolument qu'on peut accrocher sur le
frigo ou ailleurs et ça je pense que ça
a manqué voyons maintenant si ce scrutin
nous dit quelque chose de la
présidentielle de 2000 22 notamment pour
la droite pour le parti ait l'air qu'on
disait aux miettes et qui sort
finalement vainqueur de ce premier tour
20 points devant la république en marge
du poing devant le rassemblement
national pendant qu'il est dit c'est
christian jacob qui l'a dit ce matin
devant les caméras avec un petit sourire
en coin et on peut le comprendre et
xavier bertrand est l'une des
illustrations les plus marquantes de ce
ces bons résultats de la droite et du
centre en tout cas pour ce qui est des
hauts de france marion vigreux vous êtes
sur place avec jean baptiste caillaud
on pourrait se dire que c'est gagné dans
le conte de xavier bertrand
mais non on reste assez prudent je crois
on est tellement prudent que ce matin à
xavier bertrand était de retour sur le
terrain pour reprendre la campagne dès 8
heures sitôt sa liste déposée ici en
préfecture de l'île il est allé
rencontrer des élus locaux pour rappeler
son programme s'il est apparu un peu
plus détendu pas question pour le
candidat divers droite de se satisfaire
de son score au premier tour
il veut continuer à convaincre notamment
pour éloigner encore davantage son
adversaire direct
le rassemblement national le président
sortant occupe le terrain et donne le
ton de ce second tour qui restera très
disputés ici dans les hauts de france
même s'il n'ya plus vraiment de suspense
de son côté sébastien chenu le candidat
rassemblement national était sur le
marché de béthune ce midi avec une
consigne répété en boucle
allez voter d'immenses le rn qui estime
que l'abstention a joué en sa défaveur
quant à karima delli troisième de ce
scrutin
sa liste d'union de la gauche ne se
retirera pas comme en 2015 pour faire
barrage au fn
elle veut offrir une vraie place à cette
union dans l'hémicycle régional
après six ans d'absence pas de temps
mort donc ici dans les hauts de france
chacun reprend la campagne xavier
bertrand a d'ailleurs précisé qu'il
avait mis ce matin le réveil pour cinq
jours et 6 ans et ce midi nous avons
rencontré les sénateurs du nord qui
étaient à ses côtés olivier
hinault le centriste estime que la
sincérité et la transparence de xavier
bertrand notamment sur ses ambitions un
politique font son succès aujourd'hui
écoutez le et bien cette candidature
c'est donc au contraire était une forme
de booster une forme de turbo et parce
que c'est une décision claire nette et
précise assumer et je pense que les
électrices et les électeurs des hauts de
france mais aussi de notre pays ont
besoin de de cette clarté de cette
cohérence de cette vérité de cette
sincérité quand je rappelle que xavier
bertrand a fait de ce scrutin des
régionales ça primaires pour les
présidentielles aussi plus il remportera
deux voies plus en plus ils éloignent
aura à l'eurl mieux il se placera pour
l'échéance nationale de 2022 bien dans
cette direction qu'on va aller merci
beaucoup marion et merci à jean baptiste
caillaud qui vous accompagnent jean
garrigues est ce que oui ou non vous
alliez bertron avec ce score est en
position de force pour représenter la
droite à la présidentielle est ce que la
droite à son candidat
je crois en tout cas qu'il a marqué qu
il a marqué des points et des points
sérieux même si laurent wauquiez valérie
pécresse on en marquer aussi mais
précisément il est me semble-t-il
il remplit beaucoup de deux codes de
cases pardon et ils cochent beaucoup de
cases de cet hymne ajoute cette
mythologie de l'homme providentiel qui
nous poursuit de cuir depuis le général
de gaulle et qui se cristallisent
parfaitement sur l'élection
présidentielle sous là sous la vème
république à savoir que vous l'avez
remarqué il n'est plus dans le parti des
républicains
il a fait un pas de côté il se présente
comme quelqu'un qui est qui a fait une
campagne de proximité il y là il est un
président de région de deux proximité
proche du peuple qui apparaît donc un
peu distanciée des élites et il apparaît
aussi comme quelqu'un qui est porteur de
dynamisme qui est porteur de quelque
chose de nouveau c'est un nouveau
quelque part même s'il a une expérience
politique très très très ancienne mais à
tous et tous ces éléments là ce cette
dynamique que cette proximité avec avec
le peuple
et puis
cette capacité à être un tout petit peu
à côté a refusé le verdict des éventuels
primaires tout ça fait de lui quelqu'un
qui pourrait représenter une sorte de
dynamique présidentielle en 2022
ce à quoi il faut évidemment et c'est
l'aspect le plus important joindre le
fait que d'une part il a su pour
l'instant en tout cas dans sa région
relégué le rassemblement national à une
place quand même que qu'on n'attendait
pas et se débarrasser de la république
en marche c'est à dire occuper un espace
politique que jusqu'à présent qui nous
semblait qu'ils pouvaient nous semblait
à tort d'ailleurs mais qui pouvait nous
semblait totalement occupée par emmanuel
macron d'un côté marine le pen de
l'autre donc c'est très intéressant 7,7
pouces et cet élargissement de l'espace
politique des républicains
même s'il n'est plus dans le parti dans
la région nord nous nous montre que cela
est possible et que sais tu ce duel
annoncé entre marine le pen et emmanuel
macron bas n'est pas inéluctable et
c'est lui et ce qui sera crédité de 7 de
cette avancée la plus encore que laurent
wauquiez dont on attendait de toute
manière une victoire assez facile dans
sa région et plus encore que que valérie
pécresse dont la progression est moins
évidente que celle de xavier bertrand
donc je pense que il a marqué un certain
nombre de points
la course n'est pas terminée loin de là
mais il a marqué des points
est ce que vous dites nous fait beaucoup
réagir en plateau anaïs vasilis le duel
macron le pen aurait du plomb dans l
aile à cause ou grâce à xavier bertrand
je sais pas par où commencer déjà je
pense qu'il faut se dire que la
l'élection présidentielle va pas du tout
se joue avec le même niveau d'abstention
donc c'est un petit peu réducteur de
dire que là on avait une primaire de la
droite
deuxièmement ce qui convient de rappeler
c'est que l'électorat des républicains
c'est plutôt mobilisés
plus que l'électorat du rassemblement
national ou même que la france insoumise
que malgré cela ils perdent quand même
tous des voix par rapport à 2015 alors
en bout qui en a moins 45 mille voix
c'est moins 8000 valérie pécresse aussi
quelque chose d'important
donc la réussite de xavier bertrand il
faut aussi la mettre en lumière avec
celle de laurent wauquiez de valérie
pécresse donc justement mon avis ça va
juste pour créer des tensions au sein de
la droite puisque chacun va se sentir
légitime à pouvoir être candidat de la
droite aux présidentielles
je crois que là on est en train de
défier alors y'a un truc c'est qu'on dit
on il faut pas nationaliser les
élections et là on en train de se dire
ces élections sont le premier tour des
élections présidentielles donc pour vous
c'est pas une oie voyant ce qui va se
passer au second tour voyons comment les
électorats de ceux qui vont maintenir
des listes vont se comporter au second
tour et ensuite on pourra peut-être en
tirer des conclusions
un petit peu plus forte je crois qu'il
ya d'autres figures politiques qui ont
quand même marqué ces élections et qui
sont toutes des figurants nationale et
voilà que j'avais bien meurtre en a fait
de bonnes choses mais il n'ya pas que
xavier bertrand à droite est
effectivement laurent wauquiez a fait
mieux en terme de score sellal a fait un
score supérieur donc si on juge
uniquement sur le score a priori devrait
être j'irai le candidat idoine mais
c'est le côté je trouve très intéressant
de ces régionales c'est qu'au fond elle
ont effet elles ont fait émerger des
têtes d'affiché alors on les connaissait
bien sûr elle était là mais là elles
sont confortés légitimé par le suffrage
universel
et c'est vrai qu'on a tendance la
nationaliser on est parti là sur les
présidentielles mais d'un autre côté
xavier bertrand est la preuve ça marche
a quand même la jouer au stratège dire
qu'il a d'emblée annoncé la couleur
c'aurait pu être d'ailleurs pour lui
contre-productif 1 mais il a annoncé la
couleur c'était assez drôle d'ailleurs
de voir dimanche soir comment il s'est
précipité pour être le premier à parler
il a été le seul dont on a retransmis
intégralement le discours les 3000 de
discours le premier à déposer sa liste
le premier à déposer sa liste donc là il
est dans les starting blocks
mais je suis d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit je crois que on est loin de
la coupe aux lèvres là ils font quand
même encore attendre et puis il faut pas
imaginer que parce que là
la république en marche est au fond du
trou si je puis dire en termes de
suffrages
emmanuel macron est mort pas du loup je
pense que ces corrections autre chose
c'est quand même une respiration pour la
droite d'un gênant alors il ya trois
niveaux de l'analyse c'est pas un
plébiscite pour aucun des grands
présidents de région vous l'avez dit en
fait il ya 8 % des franciliens qui ont
mis un bulletin donc pécresse dans
l'urne
hier enfin pour la liste menée par
valérie pécresse il ya 14 pour sonder
auvergne rhône-alpes et donc on voit que
c'est pas un plébiscite
ce n'est pas non plus un mouvement de
fond qui a conduit à la réélection qui
n'est pas encore gagnée pour beaucoup de
ses présidents de région
donc voilà la cedh analyse à froid après
il ya l'analyse et la ayez la manière
dont l'événement est perçu notamment par
l'électorat de droite il faut bien
comprendre ce que c'est l'électorat de
droite
c'est généralement un électorat plutôt
âgée qui a voté sarkozy qui a voté
chirac qui a voté pour certains pompidou
de gaulle et qui a une vraie identité
politique mais qui est très marquée par
le culte du chef
il revient au bercail quand il croit à
une victoire 2-1 chef et il ne fait
unités il ne fait bloc malgré ces
divergences que quand il ya un chef
quelqu'un qui domine est là xavier
bertrand ou valérie pécresse ou laurent
wauquiez ont en effet une carte à jouer
parce que même si c'est pas des
plébiscites que le scrutin d'hier
et bien c'est une victoire est la
meilleure façon d'appeler une victoire
pour cet électorat c'est d'avoir déjà
gagné d'avoir justement cette aura de la
victoire et de lancer une dynamique ce
que l'on a vu lors des élections locales
qu'on avait pas vu aux élections
européennes c'est que justement quand
ceux des lecteurs croyez en la victoire
il re voter à droite quand ils n'y
croient pas ou quand il croit que sa
liste est un peu dans les choux
vous avez une partie de cet électorat un
tiers qui va vous trn et un autre tiers
qui va voter macron donc là c'est un
événement qui arithmétiquement n'est pas
écrasant et hier mais qui symboliquement
peut lancer une dynamique intéressante
après entre ses présidents de région
vous avez en effet je vous rejoins des
dynamiques aujourd'hui mais des
dynamiques qui s'opposent qui rentrent
en conflit est aujourd'hui le vrai
problème de la droite pour déclencher ce
cercle vertueux que j'ai évoqués et bien
c'est justement d'avoir non pas trois
chefs mais un seul chef n'empêchera pas
potentiellement le départage donc hier
réalité on n'a pas eu de débardage et ça
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai vrai problème
et rapidement on va voir jean daniel
levitte très rapidement et en réalité le
vrai problème par rapport à ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un appareil qui
est un débat varie de départage heller
qui ne joue pas son rôle et à défaut
d'appareils de départage eh bien vous ne
pouvez avoir qu'une neutralisation des
dynamiques
pour compléter ce qui est ce qui vient
d'être dit ce qui est ce qui va dans ce
sens et qui a pas eu de vraie stratégie
pour ces élections dans les grands
artistes d'hier et l'air entre des
alliances un côté avec la lrm et
d'autres non xavier bertrand qui part
dans dans tout seul dans son coin et de
la même chose à gauche vous regardez
d'une région à l'autre
y'a pas du tout les mêmes stratégies
d'alliance donc ça montre bien aussi la
faiblesse de ces partis à donner un
souffle un candidat unique puisque
finalement les candidats entre eux se
défonce assez facilement des partis pour
faire ce qu'il veut ce qu'ils veulent à
ces élections
ce qui est quand même inédit par rapport
à d'autres élections sabine en scène oui
je crois qu'il faut pas trop non plus
assisté sur la psychologie du peuple de
droite parce que le chef on en a besoin
pour la logique de l'élection
présidentielle et le problème se trouve
aussi à gauche oui voyez passer à gauche
on voit pas non plus de candidats ce
naturel se dégager et d'enlever un rôle
structurant des parties hors chef à
gauche qui étaient beaucoup plus forts
que justement dans dans la droite où il
avait un candidat hors parti qui peut
l'emporter beaucoup plus facilement
c'est moins qu'à gauche alors c'est un
scrutin qui nous a quand même tous un
petit peu surpris hier soir dans toutes
les rédactions et parmi les observateurs
de la vie politique que vous êtes tous
des semaines que les instituts de
sondage nous donnait le rassemblement
national en tête du premier tour dans
beaucoup de régions finalement il ne
l'est qu'en région paca alors comment
expliquer ce retournement de situation
va poser la question à jean daniel lévy
qui est en direct avec mon bonjour jean
daniel vous êtes directeur de harris
interactive france merci beaucoup
d'intervenir dans ce dans ce grand débat
lors il ne s'agit évidemment pas du tout
de s'en prendre aux sondeurs vous savez
à quel point on aime vos analyses mais
tout de même il faut admettre qu'il ya
quelque chose qui n'a pas fonctionné la
de votre côté ou pas alors j'avais un
jean daniel on ne vous entend pas
jean-daniel est-ce que vous n'entendez
nom alors je rigole oui je vous le temps
mort
vous entendez moi oui j'écris pour moi
parler du oui
on vous entend ça y est deux petites
questions sur ce qu'on a pu appeler un
ratage des instituts de sondage hier
soir cette surprise qu'on a tous eu
avait effectivement fait il ya une comme
différence entre une des dernières
intentions de vote et de vote réels des
français notamment concernant le
rassemblement national
là où on en est dans l'analyse il sait
qu on avait identifié il y avait une
baisse de la participation notamment par
rapport à 2015 mais pas une baisse non
seulement qui serait aussi importante
que celle à laquelle on l'appuie
asilaire nuit même qu'elle serait de ce
point de vue là trek iv et gêna
rationnement et socialement ce qui s'est
passé et qu'elle très forte abstention
de la part des jeunes 80 % des personnes
qu'ils soient âgés de 18 à 24 ans très
forte abstention de la part des
passionnés qui sont issus des catégories
populaires 75% des personnes qui sont
issus des milieux ouvriers mais on sait
que sont sébastien autre remake et
participer au vote en faveur de marine
le pen ou de liste qu'elle soutenait et
plus dans ce contexte là cette absence
au différentiel a fait que entre les
différentes mesures
on avait effectué il ya encore cela
quelques jours et le vote réels hier il
a ce décalage est avec l'aek notoire
mais est-ce que c'est pas quelque chose
que vous êtes censé justement anticipé
avec vos modèles est ce que il ya un
problème de méthodologie est ce que ça
va poser des questions une remise en
question en vue de la présidentielle
parce que vos sondages sont très
utilisés très éclairant pour nos débats
notamment plateau et le débat public
donc évidemment vous comprenez que ça ça
pose un peu question quand on voit les
surprises d'hier soir
je comprends pleinement la pose question
et pour le hockey tombe à regarder avec
un peu plus d'attention ce qui est un
peu surprenant c'était il ya des moments
où il peut y avoir des ascensions qui
l'ont abstention manifeste et qui ne se
traduisent pas électoralement je prends
par exemple de la surprise qu'on a eue
au vent nombre de l'élection municipale
avec une participation qu'elle
participation était extrêmement fins de
rappeler le contexte de la coved qui
commençaient à apparaître à ce moment là
est la différence entre les intentions
de vote étaient réalisés précédemment et
le comportement électoral à réels des
français était très manière peu entre
les poissons noté le comportement et le
bois qui a eu très peu de différences
ont tous rappelé qu'au cours des
actions européennes une participation au
cours de la dernière semaine qui s'est
accrue qu'on avait identifiées comme
cette façon sans que pour autant plus se
traduire en termes d'intentions de vote
les écologistes en avaient bénéficié
pour partie la formation du président
l'a dit et à l'époque les répliques
avait pâti de cette arrivée de gombo
château un des points en fait désolés
qu'elle va falloir qu'on soit encore
plus hâte entier cas encore plus
peut-être dans la pédagogie pour
reprendre le thème qui a été directeur
de montrer en fait que bêtes les ondes
de force et de fragilité de chacun de
l'électorat et la certitude de déplacés
pour aller voter de la part des
catégories de population tu peux avoir
une incidence sur le comportement
électoral en général au garage battre à
la présidentielle lorsqu'il ya une
participation qui est important ce n'est
pas l'avis général ou importantes
concernant il frange de population les
intentions de vote sont assez proches de
la réalité qu'on peut parler non
seulement d'élections très ancienne mais
on parle également des primaires et se
sont déroulés à gauche et à droite dans
le cadre de la précampagne de 2017 ou en
fait on avait identifié aussi bien par
exemple la très forte montée de français
fillon comme celle de benoît geste et
avec vos journées l on va poursuivre la
discussion avec nos invités jean
garrigues ça vous a posé question vous
aussi c'est cette surprise et surprise
de la soirée alors qu'on nous annonçait
plus ou moins j'exagère à peine
une vague est reine dans ces régionales
qui n'est pas du tout arriver
je voudrais d'abord et je n'ai pas
entendu un mouton l'intervention de jean
daniel lévy mais ça c'est pas grave
j'aurais rappeler aussi que tout à
l'heure mon propos me semble-t-il été
quelque peu caricaturée par par mes
collègues il s'agissait pas pour moi
d'annoncer la victoire de xavier
bertrand à la présidentielle mais
simplement de montrer à quel point sa
stratégie de présidentialisation de de
l'élection avait plutôt été un succès en
élargissant et en donnant l'impression
électeurs de droite qu'il y avait
éventuellement à un créneau électorale
qu'il pourrait qu'il pouvait incarner
mais pour revenir à la question de deux
des sondages
d'abord nous sommes dans une situation
tout à fait exceptionnelle n'est pas
crier haro sur les sondeurs en
considérant qu effectivement cette
situation peu avant
quelque peu décalé leur leurs résultats
il ya une deuxième explication quand
même qui est cette relation comment dire
parfois un peu incestueuses entre les
chaînes d'information les les sondeurs
qui fait qu'on a eu tendance on a eu
tendance quand même dans cette dans
cette campagne à questionner les
sondeurs ont eu tendance à orienter les
questionnements notamment autour de ce
duo infernal
macron le père autour des thèmes de la
sécurité de l'identité porté par le le
rassemblement national et on a eu
l'impression à travers tous les sondages
qui ce qui se dessinait que
qu'inéluctablement le rassemblement
national allait retirer les fruits de
cette de cette campagne de cette
atmosphère au moment des élections
régionales
or il n'en a rien été et on voit très
bien que ce sont plutôt des réflexes
conservateurs qui ont préjugé prévalu
pendant ces élections comme il avait
prévalu en réalité lors des élections
municipales dans la majorité des
communes nous et viol
le trompe-l'oeil c'était les grandes
métropoles et la poussée des faire mais
il y aurait autre chose qui se dessinait
c'était la résistance des de ce qu'on
appelle les anciens partis donc si vous
voulez une des explications de
semble-t-il de ce décalage c'est la
manière dont la campagne
la pseudo campagne a été percuté par ces
thématiques nationales et qui avait
tendance à mettre l'accent justement sur
la poussée du rassemblement lassus alors
c'est une piste il nous reste
malheureusement très peu de temps je
vais demander d'être bref et concis sur
cette question des sondages est ce que
pour vous ça pose question
moi je suis naturellement assez critique
des sondages parce qu'on a tendance
quand même les utiliser à tort et à
travers c'est un outil intéressant mais
ça ne doit pas être le seul outil
c'est pas la première fois que sur des
élections assez important enfin là elles
sont pas importantes mais en tout cas
sur des élections importantes y ait eu
des erreurs on se souvient les sondages
se sont plantés sur le bras exit les
sondages plantes sur les haies des
dernières élections américaines en
disant trump à s'effondrer et non son
électorat a résisté ce que ça monte
c'est qu'à mon avis le sondage est un
petit mais il faut aller plus loin il
faut aller vers des systèmes de
modélisation en intégrant dans les
comportements de vote les phénomène
d'abstention ce qu'on fait pas du tout
été second sondage et qui permettront
d'avoir une vision un peu plus précise
sauf que qui dit modélisation du modèle
économique un peu plus compliqué pour
les sondeurs puisque ça coûte plus cher
et donc les gens qui commandent les
sondages ne sont pas forcément prêts à
payer plus cher la deuxième chose que je
dirais sur sur les sondages c'est que là
c'est pas du tout un truc de chercheurs
c'est que ça serait bien qu'on se calme
avec l'hystérisation autour du
rassemblement national
ça fait plusieurs élections qu'on nous
fait le coup de nous dire attention le
rn url url url
quand tu es rennes ne fait pas les
résultats attendus dans les sondages en
sodia le rn chute le rnd se retrouve et
on est en train de pourrir la vie
politique en faisant ça parce qu'on
donne le sentiment qui a pas le choix ce
que c'est des élections nous monte et
qui a un un choix que deux rien n'est
écrit d'avancé et que trois le rl le
rassemblement national c'est l'histoire
d'une hystérie collective et que quand
on n'a pas de programme politique a
proposé deux transformations de la vie
des gens qu'est ce qu'on dit votez pour
nous sinon vous aurez le rassemblement
national et c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait la politique et qu'on transforme la
société alors sabine janssen benjamin
morel et je vous laisserai répondre tant
d'années mais alors vraiment tout ça
très très vite
oui il faut quand même dire à décharge
des descendeurs moi j'ai entendu brice
teinturier en début de semaine il y
disait que le rn ne serait pas très
important donc il faut pas non plus il
n'avait pas en tout cas pour ce qui
concerne ifop n'avait pas exagérer les
résultats de du rn je dirais 1
un vieux sujet à sciences po qui est les
sondages fanti l'élection eh bien non
les sondages ne font pas l'élection
effectivement on a la preuve est par
ailleurs les lecteurs ne supporte pas
qu'on lui vole sa décision qu'on lui
vole son élection est effectivement tout
est possible tout le doit rester
possible
maintenant il ya quand même question qui
va se poser c'est comment l air va
désigner son candidat à la
présidentielle puisqu'il était question
j'ai entendu à faire appel à jacques hoc
de faire appel sondages est-ce que ils
vont rétropédaler ou pas voilà une
c'est une faillite en rase campagne les
sondages on a un mystère dans cette
élection qui en réalité la
démobilisation de l'électorat populaire
qui notamment peut voter plus pour le
rassemblement national c'est vraiment ce
qui a introduit le biais cette
démobilisation de l'électorat populaire
on peut l'expliquer par rapport à ce que
l'on évoqué tout à l'heure c'est à dire
à la fois période de crise des
mobilisations cet électorat parce que
dépolitisation de l'autre vous avez un
effet de dénationalisation
paradoxalement de cette élection qui
n'est pas apparu comme évidente si
jamais je vote contre renaud muselier
est ce que vraiment je vote contre
emmanuel macron voyez tout d'un coup je
vote plus tout à fait pour ou contre le
gouvernement
donc pour une partie de l'électorat qui
n'est pas branché sur les enjeux locaux
c'est moins intéressant de se déplacer
et un troisième élément c'est que et sur
lequel leur a sûrement nationale va
peut-être devoir s'interroger c'est que
jusqu'à jusqu'aux années 2010 était pas
si exceptionnel que ça leur a sûrement
nationale mobiliser ses troupes aux
élections présidentielles et un peu
législatives mais aux élections
intermédiaires non florian philippot
avait un style et une stratégie qui
permettait justement la mobilisation de
cet électorat aux élections
intermédiaires avec une dédiabolisation
certes mais également une mobilisation
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il ya eu trop
de normalisation du rassemblement
national pour qu'il soit le réceptacle
d'une colère à ces élections
intermédiaires et à partir de là eh bien
vous avez un électorat qui retourne dans
l'apathie jordan et lévis pour conclure
je suis entièrement d'accord avec le
fait qu'il faut toujours une qualité
les enquêtes d'opinion avec prudence et
jamais considérée soit qu'il s'agit d'un
outil est totalement prédictif soi même
il s'agit d'une instruction concernant
le comportement électoral c'est une
information parmi tant d'autres lacs est
mise à la disposition à des électeurs
est mise à la disposition des
journalistes
aidé d'un ami pour entrer dans le détail
de la machine évidemment les sondeurs ne
base pas tout lors d'analysés sur des
sondages d'intentions de vote mais
également sur les sondages de
comportement sur les sondages concernant
l'abstention on cherche à travailler
justement sur des modèles également
également sur des enquêtes qualitatives
qui nous permettent de comprendre et pas
uniquement de new york
merci beaucoup jean daniel d'avoir
participé à ce débat et d'avoir accepté
de répondre à ces quelques questions un
peu plus gênante que d'habitude merci
beaucoup en tout cas nous est prêtée au
jeu merci à tous les quatre d'or
participé à cette première partie de
notre édition spéciale d'al en plus loin
ce soir lp est ce qu'ils continuent
grand débat politique à suivre